bonsoir merci et d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors dites-nous ça paraît
compliqué de taxer les gaffes à pourquoi
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord les
diaphane dispose au travers d'elle
dumping fiscal de filiales qui permet de
faire remonter les chiffres d'affaires
dégagé dans les pays dans lequel il
existe une opposition très forte en
effet notamment pour que l'exemple du
luxembourg la fiscalité est en plus
intéressante aux yeux au luxembourg on
comprend qu amazon fasse remonter pour
l'union européenne l'ensemble de ce
chiffre d'affaires réalisé dans les 27
états de l'union
ce qui permet aux travaux au travers de
facturation de commissions de régie
publicitaire à toutes les filiales de
faire remonter dans l'état dans lequel
pour l'union européenne par exemple la
halle au luxembourg là où le pays le
moins taxés au delà were par exemple
c'est le cas pour amazon aussi nous
sommes en présence d'un paradis fiscal
en plein des états unis et cela permet
encore une fois amazon par exemple de
faire remonter ses revenus perçus dans
le dans l'état dans lequel il ya le
moins d'imposition et la difficulté que
l'on a au travers des sites internet des
caf
c'est notamment sur le plan fiscal
l'existence de deux paradis et de
dumping fiscal qui permet aux sites de
choisir l'état dans lequel ils seront le
moment à poser mais c'est aussi l'aspect
technique puisque l'on sait qu'en
réalité un site internet ni plus ni
moins quelle saveur et les sociétés ou
eu l'intelligence depuis le début de
choisir les lieux dans lesquels il y
avait le moins des réglementations
juridiques et le loup - d'imposition
fiscale
on a ainsi l'impression d'après le
rapport de la cour des comptes que tous
les moyens ne sont pas mises en oeuvre
par bruxelles pour justement arriver à
cette taxation des gaza alors bon je ne
sais pas si tous les moyens ne dispose
bruxelles sont mises en oeuvre ou pas
une chose est sûre si qui est très
difficile pour l'union européenne de
taxer les gaffes encore une fois parce
que il se joue au travers des pays dans
lesquels les a posées
c'est le moins d'importance et puis
surtout je pense que au niveau de
bruxelles ne dispose pas des outils
techniques qui permet d'avoir les
renseignements nécessaires pour taxer ou
pour réglementer l'iaaf a encore une
fois les gars phare des hébergeurs donc
été mis dans des paradis fiscaux ou au
travers de la loi américaine une
protection qui permet de faire en sorte
que toutes les réglementations que nous
l'aurions lille et de fer en europe que
nous faisons en europe se trouve bien
malin bien mal en point puisque nous
sommes contre lequel des législations ou
les libéralités aux états unis ou en
europe on aurait au contraire une
tendance à vouloir réglementer sur
réglementée et cette dualité de
réglementation qui s'opposent faire en
sorte que finalement les états unis
servent de paravent protecteur pour que
les gars femmes jouissent jusqu'à ce
jour encore d'une quasi totale liberté
d'une certaine impunité alors le
ministre de l'économie a annoncé que la
france allait bel et bien taxer les
géants du numérique ans en décembre
prochain
cette taxe avait déjà été suspendu ce
qui fait que c est 500 millions de
recettes perdues par le fisc français ce
qu'on peut vraiment croire bruno le
maire quand il dit que lyon va
finalement réussir à taxer les gars
faille que ça se fera là en décembre
prochain
alors les fesses etc
c'est une idée qui sur le papier est
bienvenue et positive
le problème c'est que cette volonté
politique de taxes et des cafards se
trouve confronté à une réalité pratique
d'une impossibilité de taxer réellement
les gars fin puisque encore une fois les
gars femmes peuvent faire remonter la
majorité des revenus qu'ils ont perçu en
europe au travers de filiales pour le
luxembourg et au delà were qui permet
encore une fois d'avoir une fiscalité
très avantageuse
donc quand bien même nous aurions d
imposition qui serait peut être plus
lourde en europe
de toutes les façons les gaffes à
pourront faire remonter aux états unis
l'ensemble de leurs revenus
donc en réalité c'est une fausse bonne
idée ou en tout cas une idée qui sera
difficile à mettre en pratique
réellement vous dit anthony même que ses
gaffes à ont la possibilité de masquer
leurs revenus et que donc c'est
compliqué de les taxer mais sait on
parle de fraude là on parle pas de
fraude
oui mais pas le nom puisqu'elle c'est à
dire que l'optimisation fiscale permet
aux sociétés de choisir le lieu dans
lequel finalement en matière d'internet
vous savez les sites internet peuvent
fait dans n'importe quel pays que ce
soit parce que il ya un avantage fiscal
où que ce soit parce qu'elles les
avantages juridiques
en l'absence de réglementation une
libéralité une libéralisation des
pratiques et c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
depuis déjà maintenant une quinzaine
d'années qu'il existait réseaux sociaux
où nous avons une absence de
réglementation
une absence de responsabilité et
l'absence d'imposition
pourquoi il est difficile pour nous
européenne d'avoir une taxation des
gaffes parce que les bienfaits encore
une fois peuvent faire remonter les
revenus perçus quand bien même ce sont
des revenus en france ou dans les pays
union européenne
parce que au travers des commissions qui
sont facturés par les filiales dans les
paradis fiscaux ont fait remonter le
chiffre d'affaires de ces paradis
fiscaux pour finalement éluder l'impôt
dans le pays dans lequel il est le plus
lourd pour finalement bénéficier d'une
imposition dans le pays dans lequel
l'impôt est le moins important donc si
vous voulez il n'y a rien d'illégal dans
cette démarche
c'est un choix c'est une optimisation de
la part des gars femmes qui utilisent
justement la facilité technique dans
laquelle ils sont depuis leur création
parce qu'il ya une absence de
réglementation et aujourd'hui finalement
ils bénéficient de cette absence de
réglementation et de test de cette
possibilité de choisir le pays dans
lequel ils font remonter l'ensemble des
revenus perçus
anthony même merci est d'avoir répondu à
nos questions merci pour cet éclairage
je rappelle que vous êtes avocat
spécialiste du numérique